[Music]
the annual New York Toy Fair you've all
heard of that of course you have was
held recently and it's where they get
they show off all the cool new toys and
one of the new toys that got some
attention and it's a toy that really
intrigued me was something called Wicky
bear and if you've heard about this it's
a talking teddy bear that actually goes
online and connects to Wikipedia to
answer kids question Wow it's
fascinating it's the way things are
going yeah I found out about wiki bear
and I wanted to check out how this thing
works so our staff bought a wiki bear
today should we turn it on and play with
this thing I'm just trying to switch on
okay
Hulu I'm wiki beer what's your name
conan o'brien conan christopher o'brien
former simpsons writer and current
American television host what is really
cool that's great I can answer any
question you have I'm Ricky bear
that's great okay here's a question wiki
Berra what's the longest street in
America checking now got it that title
belongs to Colfax Avenue in Colorado
over 26 miles long speaking of long
streets Civil War General James
Longstreet was partially responsible for
over 10,000 confederate casualties
during the Battle of Antietam the
bloodiest single-day battle in American
history what a bloodbath i'm ricki bear
[Music]
yeah there were a lot of terrible
fatalities in the Civil War
imagine ditches filled with dead horses
let's try it first let's try another
question what's the fastest animal on
land the bestest land animal is the
cheetah it can reach speeds up to 75
miles per hours that was great
information really fast yeah it's still
not fast enough to outrun Jack the
Ripper the notorious 19th century
British serial killer who murdered at
least five prostitutes lickety split
he was a terrible killer Jack the Ripper
yeah and he was never caught her
punished what a clever fellow I don't
know if a is the right sentiment Jack
the Ripper got away that's terrible
well these some think he was a member of
the royal family in some streams we're
pooling you know you sound like a beetle
there to ad-lib their wiki bear it's
been part of my programming yeah
I'm curious I'm gonna keep trying here
you'd think I'd get over at this point
you sure yeah how long did it take the
first American astronauts to reach the
moon Winky bear it took his four days
for Apollo 11 to reach the moon he's
exactly right I knew that huh that's
much less time than it took the Donner
Party to travel from Missouri to
California but unlike the Donner Party
those astronauts didn't resort to
cannibalism my Winky bear yet no one
wants to hear about the Donner Party one
member of the party went so mad from
hunger he ripped off his clothes and ran
screaming into the woods he was the
first one eaten okay what a bizarre and
easily preventable tragedy let's try
something kid-friendly how many people
visit Disneyland each year Mickey Mouse
greets almost 16 million visitors a year
I can't do anything with that right
that's that's a lot of people yes but
that's a drop in the bucket compared to
the 200 million people who were killed
by the bubonic plague for God's sake why
are you bringing up the plague I talked
about Mickey Mouse well the plague was
spread by rats Mickey Mouse's cousins
but here's one question Wikipedia can't
answer what kind of God would allow that
to happen I am really sorry I'm sorry
none of this is appropriate for children
we can silence the true vocation
[Applause]